von hebel
[Musique]
prendre des vacances
c'est devenu presque facile pour
beaucoup d'entre nous mais sur les 27
millions de français qui ne partent pas
il y a les vieillards 30000 à paris dans
l'aide sociale s'occupe régulièrement
pour eux qu'en est il peuvent-ils partir
le souhaite il
comment se passent les journées pour
vous vous venez souvent dans ce genre
ont lieu tous les deux points qui
prévaut quatrième felice dans la nuit
tandis que l'ingénieur de tourner tout
votre corps
quelqu'un avec qui parler vous passez
tous vous était à paris match il voulait
m'amener cette année avec l réalité rue
à la mer mais je produis selma solide
encore ils ont mille qui des escaliers
remonte à 1888 ans depuis quand n'avez
vous pas quitter paris je sais pas
il y a dix ans rien n'existait pour les
vieillards
cette année neuf mille personnes
partiront sous le patronage du conseil
de paris mais beaucoup de gens
n'imaginent même pas qu'il pourrait
prendre des vacances ailleurs que dans
l'espoir
vous partez en était à nos avants paris
ma cheminée à paris eh ben même dans
l'état guinéen gris vert blanc paul biya
et bien je reste
le père marc
de 7,8 à bloquer avanciez aussi célébré
cornes des mâles thorn 2 h
bon
[Musique]
a paris je veux ma mère mon père je
revois mes copains qui sont presque tous
morts mes copines aussi qui sont presque
tous morts et bien c'est paris tandis
que la campagne oui le grand problème
c'est la solitude quitté son quartier
c'est ce coupé du monde souvent le
vieillard n'a plus de famille et pour
l'aider à rompre le cercle magique des
souvenirs il faut créer un lien qui le
rattache à la vie
quel âge avez vous encore vous êtes déjà
partis en vacances non jamais pour
quelles raisons manque d'argent en peu
de temps la guerre et où je suis pas
parti
le regretter
bonne chance oui j'ai pas mon copain et
maintenant vous avez la possibilité de
partir il ment il ya 30 ou combien
touche et vous quarante familles par
mois vous avez des enfants vous êtes
simple j'ai une fille mais est tellement
loin et à 50 ont pas fait l oblige à moi
j'ai plus ma fille
mon bonnet
que faites vous de vos journées à paris
au le vide
[Musique]
ils ont constaté déjà depuis une dizaine
d'années que une d un des facteurs
aggravants les phénomènes de sénescence
de vieillissement était est et la
solitude et la rupture des liens avec le
milieu professionnel est souvent est un
milieu familial alors l'objet de la
politique du pire aux aides sociales en
matière de personnes âgées objets qui
était l'objectif qui a été fixé par
notre conseil d'administration
c'est précisément de faire tout ce qui
était en notre pouvoir pour réintégrer
finalement la personne âgée dans la
société est tissée autour d'elle un
nouveau tir un nouveau tissu affectif et
sentimental destinée précisément à
rompre cet isolement
c'est à travers l'existence des clubs
chaque quartier possède au moins un que
la personne âgée peut s'informer sur les
possibilités de vacances
les départs ont lieu hors saison en mai
juin ou septembre
la durée du séjour de semaine en france
ou dans les pays de soleil la corse où
les balais à le prix
si une personne âgée ne dispose pas de
plus de 1050 francs par trimestre l'aide
sociale ne lui demandera aucune
participation pour ces vacances au delà
sa contribution financière présentera un
centième de sa retraite déduction faite
du loyer
[Musique]
quand on m'a envoyé quand on me propose
des vacances j'y vais mais bien sûr je
vais aller un homme l'a proposé m'a
écrit de pamiers le contraire et
contraire oui avant j'allais avec mes
enfants y avait près une dizaine
d'années mais comprenez quand alors
accouché par faire j'aime la page est
tournée
non je vais je vais un jour dans ma
famille je devais partir à guidel il y
avait deux voyages et sur des deux
voyages il y en a supprimés donc j'ai
reçu un mot du bureau d'aidé sociale
comme quoi ce ne devait pas y compter
pourquoi alors j'ai demandé à monsieur
colin pourquoi alors donc il faut qu'une
personne se des 6 ou qu'une personne
tombe malade
aucune personne par pour le long voyage
vous avez envie d'aller au bel et bien
vu mon âge je sais pas que ça me fait
peur l'avion je les primes déjà un avion
mais dis moi j'ai peur qu'il arrive
quelque chose la part non mais on est
bien quand même ici et ce qu'ils m'en
voyez vous cite un dard non pas pour
l'alcool à mais pour une petite bière
quoi est-ce que ça vous arrive de
quitter paris de partir en vacances 21
la commande est bon jour on est des
vieux retraités qui touchent tous pris
quelques gros balourd c'est pas possible
lorsque vous partez en vacances oui
est-ce que cela vous revient cher non
ils vous payez ou d'après le prix de
votre retraite madame et vous savez je
suis parti en corse le premier voyage
que j'ai fait je suis parti en corse
trois semaines et j'ai mangé comme les
personnes qui paient 7000 francs avec le
bungalow nouveau jour la même chose et
vous payez combien à ce moment là moi
j'ai payé 6 milles près de 7000 pour
partir trois semaines
donc c'est assez concluant en c'est
merveilleux l'avion locard un bungalow
tout ce qui est bien c'est merveilleux
et ben moi je suis heureuse
et j'aurais voulu que ma mère soit
heureuse comme moi elle a eu dix enfants
on s'est jamais occupé d'elle c'était
moi qui gagnait 40 souffert jours et j'y
donnais 20 sous il m'a restés vains
jamais jamais on ne l'a aidé donc ce
moment là vous n'êtes jamais parti en
vacances à jamais ce pas ce que c'était
c'est depuis que je suis vieille ses 80
non situation paradoxale
cette vielle aure sont heureux ils
partent les autres les envies faut-il
mérité ses vacances lorsqu'on est âgée
non répond le bureau d aide sociale de
paris le budget vacances est de 256
millions d'anciens francs pour 1973
mais faire cohabiter 30 à 50 personnes
pendant quinze jours demande de la
prudence
deux critères pour partir être en
parfaite santé
les dernier examen médical a lieu la
veille du départ avoir bon caractère
s'adapter à la vie communautaire et
c'est bien difficile quand on est
attaché à sa solitude
alors il reste une solution le
dépaysement limitée dans le temps
c'est un petit gros
un guide qui peut il fait expliqué
patrick personnes ont recours aux
personnes non non non la reprendre cette
année nous avons environ 3000 personnes
qui seront partis pour une quinzaine de
jours lors soit à l'étranger soit en
métropole et notamment juan les pins et
nous aurons environ 8000 à 9000
personnes qui partiront qui partiront
pour des voyages de courte durée oui il
y a encore de grands projets pour le
bureau dette sociale
mais il y aura toujours des vieillards
pour qui le plus beau voyage ne vaudra
pas la vie du quartier
l'avis du square
[Musique]
on rencontre toujours les mêmes
personnes dans les squares à peu près ou
de rivas connais pas tellement soir les
pompiers parce que c'est beaucoup plus
grand mais la banque d'histoire du
commerce à longue se connaît à peu près
tous
alors vous comprenez quand on va entrer
bah oui ça n'en finit plus on connaît
l'histoire qui vont nous raconter parker
non les coudes quand même hein ben oui
parce que quand même
[Musique]